towns practically obliterated after last
night's tornado 23 people have been
confirmed dead so far many are still
missing
severe storms hit the states of
Mississippi Alabama and Texas on Friday
evening
the destruction was most felt in the
rural Mississippi towns of Silver City
and Rolling Fork before continuing
sweeping Northeast towards Alabama at 70
miles per hour
in Texas two tornadoes with a hundred
miles per hour winds struck around 5am
on Friday leaving five people injured
satellite images have captured the
magnitude of the storm but its impact
was most felt on the ground
is really
yeah
with my every trailer in this town gone
the power lines down fifteen thousand
homes are without electricity in
Mississippi right now we got multiple
homes damaged in the Silver City area
also in other parts of the area of the
county we're going to have a makeshift
shelters at the multi-purpose building
Volunteers in these close communities
have been quick to offer help but with
authorities warning that the death toll
will rise it may not be enough
Alice Porter Sky News